all societies most societies and most
nations are built off a core family
nuclear family structure okay the West
seems to be straying more away from a
nuclear family structure and so if the
men are building a society right
generally men build societies women
nurture what's in the society so if the
men are building the society and women
are nurturing what's in society and like
I said the women aren't right and we
need a nuclear family structure yet and
still this this Society teaches women to
be independent you don't need a man you
can do it all by yourself okay that is
going to affect the moral fabric of the
society in which we live in but if you
make the point about women making bad
choices about Partners if they stop
making those choices then they're wrong
for making the choices not to be with
Partners who are going to be horrible to
them wait because it's weird so because
of feminine sexual Liberation they don't
need a man they become independent
that's what I think yes but it's come
from a space where women make choices to
be with the wrong men so they decide to
make different choices to be independent
to not pursue those options so then
what's what's the right choice so you're
saying that they made that choice
because of
so so in in this situation where Monroe
made the decision to be with those toxic
really just as an example not her
specifically but made that choice to be
in those toxic relationships and and now
we're on the other side where women are
choosing to be independent choosing not
to be in those toxic relationships
rather choosing to support themselves
than rely on someone who's going to
ultimately harm her
um she made those choices to be with
those women but that's what I'm saying
so why are the only why are the only two
options pick a bad guy or be by yourself
because some people don't actually have
a choice I think I think a lot of women
so when I think about my grandma or you
know the men that she was dating
whatever
um at that time you didn't really have a
job if you're a woman it wasn't really
you basically forced not to basically
and then the men that came to you were
your options right she had two options
both were not very nice men and once you
get into relationship you can get you
can fall in love with a narcissist and
he could be amazing and then you marry
them and then they just well every
single day and without any Financial
Freedom or Independence you can't leave
right so in this Society it's like look
you could live today you could get a job
yeah I mean just because you don't like
your options you could get a job in the
past but what you're saying is with a
nuclear family the woman stays home she
doesn't go to work she's not independent
that's kind of what I'm hearing maybe
that's not what you meant but if a woman
can't be financially independent and
free then some people don't actually
have that choice in being able to leave
a violent relationship I'm not saying
girls can't be financially independent
like they can they can go be financially
independent but what I'm saying it's not
conducive for families right so like
kids it's better for them to have a mom
and a dad in the hole right that's
incredibly hard to normal or a
heteronormative as well right there's
something sorry what's header I don't
know sorry as in like um straight
couples right there are so many
different family dynamics that can like
supportively and genuinely raise it so
so I will say on this show we try to
stick to the rule rather than the
exception
63 of Youth suicides yeah are from
single mother homes 90 of homelessness
and runaway children are from Singles
you can't put that on the mother 85 of
children who show behavioral disorders
are from single mother homes 80 of
rapists with anger problems are from
single mother homes 71 of high high
school dropouts are from single mother
homes 70 of youths in operated
institutions are from single mother
homes 80 of all the youths that in
prison are from single mother homes
guys why is your immediate reaction
you're blaming the woman when he's just
reading a stat because I think we where
this conversation was going was like you
know what women need to behave and women
need to act correctly and then life
would be sweet there have been more
nuclear families like that's not the
case there's a lot of relationships that
don't work and for a lot of women the
best situation they can like they can
and give to their child to say I'm going
to leave this man you know what I'm
saying the man lives
so true women leave 70 to 80 of the time
I'm pretty sure now it's 80 and if
you're college educated it's 90 so women
are the ones leaving is and and the
other thing is like the reason the
reason I would put it on the woman is
because you pick who you have a baby
with so so
we're the we're in the UK now right and
abortions legal up to six months yeah
you pick who you have a baby with you're
you you get an out but what if you have
a baby with someone believing that
they're a genuine person that they're
going to step up and then they choose in
my experience that's the exception it's
not the rule because what I see is girls
see the red flags early on they keep
dating him and then it goes poorly and
they're crying later but it's like you
saw the 10 million red flags before you
had the kids there's so many different
things involved in not seeing red flags
there are so many different mental
health issues there's so many different
societies there's so many excuses
but there's a reason for it there's a
reason that's an excuse it doesn't mean
it's not justified it sound like you
have a lot of excuses for women I don't
have excuses for a woman I don't
understand
been through to me it's just taking
accountability I think the conversation
is like you're trying to say it's
everything's really black and white yeah
this is the reason why women leave all
the time like there's so relationships
are so complex that looking at a stat
you can't be like okay well it's women's
fault they need to behave yeah but the
results is what matters what matters is
not your feelings what matters is the
results at the end of the day and so if
the results are a certain percentage of
women 80 are leaving marriages your
feelings don't come into the situation
because what's happening is because
everyone's going to have different
feelings right this woman said it was
because of that reason that woman said
it because of that reason it was because
of this but at the end of the day the
result is it's 80 of women leaving
marriage
and at the end of the day it's the kids
who suffer because you're putting your
feelings above the kids and this is I'm
taking out exceptions like abuse outside
outside of abuse you're putting your
your feelings above the children do you
not think if men behave better women
would stay because women are now you
know you have to be responsible you have
to get a job but also you have to do the
domestic labor you have to do the
emotional labor men to in today's
society like yeah you have to get a job
and you have to like isn't it
sexist yeah but like yeah but yeah I
don't understand why it's okay to be
openly sexist against men but it's not
sex because what is what I said if women
just behaved better that it would be
better because
I was only saying that to like combat
saying oh it's the women's fault
we're not saying America be a better
husband and could help around the house
more the fact that men help around the
house when it's their house as well like
that's literally what it's called like
there is a like a disparity with the
amount of Labor that women do and that
men do yeah men make more money
statistically so you could just say the
main contribute more yeah
if a dude's paying my right he's not
doing [__] he's not doing [__] around
the house but women also work so they're
also doing a nine to five like maybe a
third so like when I'm saying
statistically men make more money I just
so go ahead I just wanted to ask all
your statistics and your percentages all
of that where did you find it is it in
the UK is it in the U.S UK and U.S
there's a little bit of a disparity yeah
between the UK and U.S specifically when
it comes to divorce is 64 percent in the
UK and it's 80 in us who carried out
um the government the government studies
how many women 100 women and then ask
them about the life